ist für uns jetzt in big apple in new
york uns zugeschaltet arbeit ostern in
new york die die stadt ist sowieso
lahmgelegt wie wurden die feiertage
dauert nun verbracht
es waren wirklich die allerschnellsten
tage die ich jemals erlebt aber in new
york die stadt praktisch ausgestorben
natürlich auch die kirchen alle
zugesperrt teilweise sogar mit essen
schlossen die gottesdienste beamten im
internet statt natürlich die eigentlich
überall auf der welt ein wirklich sehr
ruhiges new yorker u-bahn menschen die
man sagt hier aus dem zum spazieren um
zum joggen eigentlich die größte band
stampfen gab es in new york
traurigerweise bei einer suppenküche in
der bowery switcher dort haben hunderte
menschen angestellt
für einige eine gratis x pert am
ostersonntag das natürlich ein anzeichen
wie schlimm auch die wirtschaftlichen
lage mittlerweile ist in new york und im
rest amerikas viele menschen haben ihre
arbeitsplätze verloren handlung keine
andere möglichkeit mehr als um einen
gratis essen zu stellen und diese szenen
sieht man hier in new york immer öfter
reicht eigentlich jeden tag schlimme
nachrichten und dramatische bilder aus
new york von dir wir sehen dort die zahl
der infizierten steigt immer weiter aber
vor allem auch die zahl der todesfälle
aufgrund der korona erkrankung sind
extrem hoch in new york kann man schon
eine erste bilanz jetzt ziehen weiß man
schon wie die entwicklung weitergeht es
der höhepunkt erreicht wir sind jetzt
ungefähr am höhepunkt oder vielleicht
ganz knapp darüber dass die tatsache
dass ist bei den lieferungen nicht die
fehler
starke rückgänge gibt auch die sitz und
nervende vier rennen hier heule dass man
hier wochenlang gehört dass an etwas
nachgelassen offensichtlich werden
weniger menschen eingeliefert ins spital
allerdings die zahl der toten ist nach
wie vor sehr hoch auch wenn sie jetzt
nicht mehr steigt aber gouverneur andrew
cuomo hat neulich bekannt gegeben am
sonntag dass die
die bilanz für den bundesstaat new york
7 150 tote betragen haben an einem tag
hier in new york ist die opferbilanz
jetzt insgesamt bereits auf fast 7.000
punkte gestiegen das natürlich sind
wirklich dramatische zahlen mehr als
doppelt so viele menschen gestorben als
bei den terroranschlägen des 11
septembers natürlich sorgt nach wie vor
keine wirklich beklemmende bedrückende
stimmung hier in new york und natürlich
auch für viel trauer
man darf ja nicht vergessen hier in new
york mittlerweile jeder irgendjemanden
der amateur am groner wäre es ja gar
nicht ist aber auch gestorben ist das
ist natürlich auch politisch ein großes
thema jetzt in den usa und zu erreichen
auch hilferufe nicht nur aus new york
sondern aus einem möglichen städten der
usa vor allem aus krankenhäusern
wie reagieren die menschen darauf vor
allem wie reagieren sie darauf wie trump
jetzt mit dieser corona krise in seinem
land umgeht
die us-bundesstaaten haben eine wirklich
solide arbeit geleistet wird mir gesagt
ist wie spitalswesen hauptsächlich
gehalten haben spitäler nicht an den
rahmen des zusammenbruchs gebracht
wurden das ist eine hervorragende
leistung allerdings was den
amerikanischen präsidenten mit rich text
wickeln sich vor allem an der tatsache
dass erst so lange gezögert reagieren
auf das virus ist immer mehr gerichte
wie etwa ein haben der der debattieren
der report in der new york times wo
aufgezeigt wurde wie oft der
amerikanische präsident gewarnt wurde
das ganze ging los aber bereits im
januar dann weiter im februar immer
wieder habe der präsident diese
warnungen in den wind geschlagen hat
immer wieder das virus verharmloste
hatten offensichtlich mehr sorgen macht
um die amerikanische wirtschaft alles um
die menschen leben hier in den usa holt
ihn jetzt natürlich ein der top biologe
in den usa doch beendet ist
der hoch angesehen ist hier in amerika
hat es auf den punkt gebracht erst sagt
er bedauert dass man mehr
man hätte mehr menschenleben retten kann
dann wenn man früher reagiert hätte und
das natürlich auch wenn man früher
reagiert heißt es natürlich ist ein 2
auch us präsidenten donald trump und wer
hat bereits dauer reagiert der hat in
einem tweet angedeutet dass er endlich
vielleicht bei vielen dank dir herbert
bauernebel aus den usa du wirst uns
weiter auf dem laufenden darüber halten
wie die situation sich dort jetzt
weiterentwickelt wir haben gehört die
zahlen sinken nun langsam trotzdem noch
kein grund jetzt für entwarnung aus new
york und aus den usa